dea
今から日本語のレッスンを行います
リュックに着替えとタオルを入れる他人の体を創造して劣等感覚え
家を出て温泉に向かう劣等感覚える温泉施設に入る裸になるのを避けようとしてロビー
のクレーンゲームで遊ぶ
ロビーのカウンターの裏に立っているのです
ちゃんと目が自分の体を守ってるっ10日に溺れる
お姉さんから視線をそらす自販機で入浴券を買おう
緊張しながら立つ以上にある劣等感のあまりに間違えて女性の脱衣場に入ってしまった
ことに気づく急いでね男性の脱衣場に入る他人の体を見るんだと思いながら他人の体を
見てしまう
ロッカーに萩を挿入する
日本なんかこなければ良かったとも他人のインドを見るなーと思いながら他人の陰部を
見てしまうリュックを開け
あ家にはされたんだ東大きくつぶやき変える言い訳を作る温泉施設から飛び出して自分
を非難しながら part 2モード凹み
翌日の仕事を休ま1日他人の体を創造して劣等感覚える
うつを忘れようとして
ev を見る av を観ることで劣等感をつのらせさらに深刻なうつに陥る
また仕事を休んで家に引き込むイギリスにいる精神科医からスカイプカウンセリングを
受け始める
スーパーでカップヌードルを見比べている時にが効く
ずれる親に電話して普通に元気にやってるよとウソをつく不安を克服するために二重
人格を作るとスター s キーを読む
村上を読むスカイプカウンセリングを止めるスカイプカウンセリングを続ける
ニーチェのと村上を読む超人もそ抱き
燃えるゴミにわざとペットボトルを入れて外に出す罪悪感のままに
の中にゴミを治すコンビニからお汁とエッグサンドんです
2時間後に戻ってこっそりと216円をカウンターに置くほどでわざと人にぶつかって
そのまま去っていく
あいさつしてくる大家さんにとなってエレベーターに乗り込む
どうかのゴキブリを激しく踏みつける向きながら skype カウンセラーに手を
するが繋がらない座薬か
お怒りでごまかしものがそうあ声をかぎり枕に先程かかってくるカウンターからの電話
に出る
味方も優しい声を聞いて徐々に落ち着く午前一時まで話す決意してふとにアイル橙色の
朝焼きに目を覚ますリップに着替えとタオルを入れる
他人の体を創造して劣等感覚え温泉施設に入る
時半
機で入浴券を買おう別当コンボへ男性の脱衣場に入る日本なんかこなければ良かったと
思うず分
イギリスのカウンセラーに電話しなきゃという強い衝動た高尾パンツ脱いで六花を占め
震える手でタオルを頭に浴場に向かう
劣等感を覚える狩りを感じる不安不安にリクビクしながらからだ
12人が発生をシャワーで流す周りを気にしつつ
やがって大浴場に入るそして5分後にみーちゃんの住んでいた街にも温泉があれば
よかったのにと思うん
ni